and that's why I think it's I'm giving
you good advice because I think you are
man your maturity manifests
professionally into something that looks
like the part that I just told you and
that's when the street hustler makes 139
I'm mommy doesn't not a bad I grab you
come back like a visible and acting with
clarity hustle like my name is Gary
Thomas I've been telling you accounts of
sort of my equity
I'm triple-a given a pedigree to mean
enough pleasure my specialty including
the work that I'm doing are the moving
furniture heaven
[Music]
I've been looking forward to my life
changed circle getting smaller items
like strange that does have me young
man's as a teenager homies morphing on
me like the Green Ranger I was running
from saying Johnny and I was coming from
nice in the master result I got a
honey-do cuz I've been hanging with the
brothers and swimming with the sharks to
get to the site I had to go through the
darkest of races and I turn them into
strengths to my gelling and I channeled
on my bank to blend it on the beauty in
the place so it's once again every turn
of what it takes the pretended you could
say to me I've been living gratefully I
am so damned if you visit any place for
me when it changes a knucklehead think I
was raised only that's what made me me
you know when I heard your interview on
the record of it I mean I mention this
is a holiday party
I remember I'm just like listen this guy
has like you you you pump me up you let
me know
like stop you know crying about being
excuses for yourself like you're not at
the place you want to be that's fine but
make changes you know do what you have
to give so much control people don't
feel it but they do and the game is not
interested in that game is not
interested in making it easy for you
especially when you got points against
you yeah problem is there's just no
choice
[Music]
this is a lot of ways to sit about this
I would tell you to meet as many people
here as possible
I mean people of the game right like
right in house like cafeteria like work
out of the cafeteria for an hour every
day because it's the people right like
it's some 22 year old guy right now
who's eventually going to have his own
business some 24 year old girl that's
going to be in politics like it's a
human that's going to create the most
rich up opportunities and friendships I
think that would be game-changing what
do you do hey or if you're in a good
meeting where you just said Pinterest
and you like the vibe of that person who
the knows what she or he does as you
walk out and be like hey thanks for like
the love in that room like you made me
feel good okay let's get a drink after
work one day or you want to get a [ __ ]
here you want to have lunch one day
together just be in the office like I
genuinely genuinely believe that people
are scared to not be nice here because
they know I give a [ __ ] so much about it
and I think you should take advantage of
that cool thank you have a great day you
know such a pleasure take care have the
best day yes
Thank You Julia
hey Skylar I'm doing really well man how
are you doing right
good man how long you been here awesome
how's it going do great good really
really good
tell me about yourself everybody good
time we've got to keep fighting
wrestling app and every time that I'm
writing down I live in my pack ilaria
shall see I'm Gary it was something that
was in your plans - they say - yes
finishes everything I'm drinking on the
rocks that'll make you vomit on me if it
ain't broke don't fix it used to get
with people today I'm just living my
life the key I get when I'm sipping wine
so we Vista and it made me feel
different I just feel like good brother
how are you good man like a shirt thank
you welcome one of my desires is wearing
it seriously that is not a bad day to
like wear the same shirt I think it's
kind of cool yeah
how about one the guys we're just gonna
void him all day love it brother go back
a couple starts looking dirty ass kick
no I'll leave a peg legs when I'm
throwing a trick this entire thing it's
not just build the greatest business of
all to build a four hundred four point
three billion dollar revenue business
and be nice there's all these things in
between and one of the in betweens or
things like the alumni program like what
if I built one of the great businesses
of this generation and what that meant
was every one of those [ __ ] out there
had a lump an alumni program which is
offense
yeah it's awesome instead of defense
like I want to know what everybody's
thinking but I'd no [ __ ] clue
[Music]
now changing we give is like we're a 14
year old supermodel which means we're
six foot one and we have zits and braces
and we're still getting made fun of by
the same guys who are going to rip their
arms off to date us in seven years
that's the punchline that's straight-up
Matt being better than being a 14 year
old supermodel is I can speed up that
process I don't have to just wait six
more you know what I mean exactly I
don't have to wait six four more years
for me to become the Swan I'm doing
everything I can to make that happen
quicker but I don't get crippled by the
medium term right I like pacing and
seeing and watching you know like it's
about Talent
it's about meritocracy it's about doing
it's about being smarter I think a lot
of things that I think are going to make
a lot of us sense to you while making
sure we do not replicate where you came
from because I see a real interest first
of all you're about to get really happy
with me because I have a funny feeling
you're the kind of character that's
about to really make some money on what
I'm about to say some reason my spidey
senses to stay in kombu cream says to me
cool before we get into like the cliche
answers I could give you which are
probably right about how to figure out
making it worth something and like
what's the balance of building personal
brand and IP
and giving away and not giving away
which is alright you should sleep on one
other thing which is I think you can
actually build
I think you can actually go all the way
I think you're young enough and
potentially balanced out by the humility
of your experience have the right
balance of humility and magic to at
least challenge yourself over the next
little piece of time of what I build on
pliers because I was a kid nobody owns
it or maybe somebody doesn't matter the
game okay - I'm really good for giving
you advice because we almost basically
live the same life so we share DNA
it's the ultimate arbitrage you make
your money by arbitrage
within the system you can arbitrage the
system I mean he did yeah after you do
homework and you're like okay when I'm
42 years old in seven years he's right
this is actually going to be as big as
UFC a bro if we were sitting in 1963 the
NFL was [ __ ] dude the 1983 NBA Finals
was on tape delay and that's why I think
it's I'm giving you good advice because
I think you are man after maturity
manifests professionally into something
that looks like the part that I just
told you and that's when the street
hustler makes 130 million
I figured it out you know so my man real
pleasure
yeah let we'll do that thank you let's
see broth it's definitely wrong nobody
else gets the cross-dressing hitting
hands let me get in here need me to get
in here oh you will demonstrate hi
Astrid are you doing do you know that do
you know that she fell for the April
Fool's joke that I'm working out and he
rolls up on me and go Steve's got voted
out of the NFL yeah how are you today
ha your scrimmage really nice you're a
nice man
how is my system yeah hey how are you
doing some photos looking Rocky films
all my stuff you good nobody where
you're filming now for your my blog
you're gonna be on it again you're like
you're like one of the favorite
characters of the whole thing
good to see you see you soon yeah cool
hey don't fill
really good yeah like wrestling the pan
every time that I'm writing every dollar
in my pocket was earned by being
righteous if you never been through with
struggles and we have no one like this I
don't know something I would dismiss my
family your plans to maintain es
business everything I'm drinking on the
racks I don't miss it mama told me if it
ain't broke don't fix they used to get
what people take I'm just living my life
excuse me I guess when I'm sippin on
some advice I'm going thank you glad we
finally made this happen
yeah me too we - I appreciate it how do
I actually say guys within a second so
the next one is II yeah give me the give
me the get nickel tour yeah hey areare
you are you
[Music]
thousand your foundation building that
[ __ ] house was good there I mean I
don't like these cloud raise like this
company their nativity they got names
validated it believed that I would order
that that the entertainment that way
without you have money Susan I like your
sneakers and welcome we want you have
smart guys so it seems like everybody's
yapping I just want to give a little
framework we've got a bunch of really
good wine which I selected for tonight
there's boy stirs and shrimp and things
of that nature and so I want to make
sure everybody knows that and so come
over and grab some will hang here for
another 15-20 minutes and then we're
going to go out back and have dinner so
I just want to thank everybody I'm
really glad we do this again I really
like this little thing is our little
thing so have fun we'll get in there a
little bit but please grab some food
because I thought sure isn't shrimp or a
big deal
thank you I'm really glad you're here
yeah for sure Cheers enjoy grab a plate
please I'm going to go first
I love boys
all right now we're going to go into a
little session with our clients you know
I know I'm a big fan of shaking hands
and kissing babies I think that for you
guys to follow me
you may be continuous about how I think
about technology in real life I believe
that technology is a gateway drug to
real life right we roll on DM and hang
out on Twitter and then we end up
shaking hands and hugging you balancing
selfie I think it's important with
clients and my organization there's a
bunch of people that work for me here a
bunch of people that are my clients
they're equally important actually the
employees are a little bit more
important but the punch line is being
together hanging jamming meeting new
friends that's the key and that's what
I'm an Alec a my time through the rest
of your night so Sirach I love you get
out of here I've been looking forward to
my life change
circle getting small the Rutles like
strength study is a great night for
Vista I was out of here I'm out of here
tomorrow night jogging I was coming from
nice in the master alone I got a
honey-do cutter I've been hanging with
the brothers is from a witness jog to
forget to decide I have to go through
the door here at Salvation senator
namenda strength to my seven and I
channeled on my Hank to plant it on the
beauty in the place on the quads against
every turn of what it takes everything
that you could say to me I've been
living crazily
is so damned if you visit any place for
me